what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time she's
laughing
because wall street's trying to get rich
russell's trying to get our lunch money
right
wrong she's not laughing because of that
she's laughing because i've been waiting
on her all day
to be ready to do this and she wasn't
ready it's fine she's literally keeps
exiting out of things that's why she's
got that face right now but don't forget
that lunch money is now sponsored by
block five block buy has three products
you can buy and sell crypto on a crypto
exchange with no fees
you can deposit crypto and take out a
usd loan and get your crypto collateral
or you can deposit crypto earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
you also can get on the waitlist go get
your
credit card they have a bitcoin reward
credit card you swipe your card
and then they pay you bitcoin back as
the reward
let's roll go to blackfy.com blockfy.com
blockfight.com i covered for you long
enough let's go
i got things to save today
what is the news microstrategy buys more
than one billion dollars worth of
bitcoin
adding to its massive holdings what is
michael saylor doing
slow down my god slow
down don't buy all the bitcoin before i
get a couple more
slow down t-o-t-o
we got micro strategy buying another
billion
my guy is not out here trying to be a
billionaire he is a billionaire
the company's dropping billies all over
the place buying bitcoin they now
have sunk more than two billion dollars
into
bitcoin it's 90 000 bitcoin they got on
their balance sheet
it's worth like 4.5 billion dollars
they kind of like the government the
government was doing billions then tens
of billions and hundreds of players now
they're printing trillions of dollars
micro strategy they started out with
hundreds of millions
now they got billions eventually gonna
have tens of billions and then at some
point
he's gonna have a hundred plus billion
dollars worth of bitcoin
it's gonna happen another company that
keeps buying bitcoin is square
jack slow down we don't need job
buying up all the bitcoins relax
he had a coffee today he also had a
micro coffee i had three coffees today
bang bang what up
kids hey kids if you're at home tell
your parents let me get some coffee
uh micro strategy has 95 plus percent of
their balance sheets
in bitcoin square has five
percent of their cash and cash
equivalents now in bitcoin
also tesla has eight percent so if your
financial advisor is telling you well i
don't think that you should own any or
if they're saying
okay let's dip our toes we'll just put
half a percent
then you should tell them well what are
all these billionaires
elon michael saylor jack dorsey what do
they know that your financial advisor
doesn't know
i watched charlie munger's uh con
shareholder thing today he ain't a fan
guys i don't know how to tell you he
ain't not a fan charlie munger doesn't
know how to turn on his computer
yes he does how do you know very
intelligent
and technologically savvy okay calling
charlie munger technologically savvy
is like calling me ugly what's your name
yeah i knew that was gonna get her
calling charlie munger
technologically savvy is like calling me
ugly do i say
it do i say it i'm not gonna say it that
was a softball that was a softball she
ain't swing
she knew that was a check swing you like
let's go to the umpire
nope didn't come across the plate there
that's a sport that's a sports analogy
you don't even understand it let's use
your inside voice do you know how to
check to the referee
it's the umpire actually but do you know
how to oh i know what an
umpire is empire what's the empire
umpire is the referee of baseball and
softball
oh that's pretty good but i don't know
if you call it a referee that's the
whole point of calling an umpire you
said referee
yeah i was misspeaking so square bought
170 million dollars more on bitcoin to
boost its crypto holdings
next top we're to discuss this one all
right i got things to
do let's go like annoy you
house democrats aim to pass 1.9
dollar trillion dollar coveted relief
bill on
friday 1.9 bill
it's late in the day my brain isn't
functioning
i am an umpire you look like a sailor
building an
empire you look like a sailor all right
so basically
uh republicans have questioned the need
for nearly 2 trillion more in spending
and argue democrats have pursued goals
unrelated to the pandemic meanwhile
people are just pursuing all sorts of
things all right we need to have it
listen we need to have a conversation i
want to have this conversation with all
of you what right now while i'm sitting
on your
phone maybe you're sitting on the toilet
taking a poop while you're watching this
maybe i'm in your living room but we
need to have a serious conversation
bitcoin there's a fixed supply all the
bitcoiners that own bitcoin
they ain't selling 60 hasn't moved in
the last 12 months hundreds of
percent appreciation 50 drop in the
price in a single day
bitcoiner still didn't sell 60 hasn't
moved
all of a sudden financial institutions
and corporations are showing up and
saying oh my god i want bitcoin
and the bitcoiner said you can't have my
bitcoin at this price and so therefore
the
us dollar price continues to appreciate
aggressively and now the government is
gonna step in and they're gonna take 1.9
trillion dollars
which is going to be the second largest
monetary policy package ever and they
are going to
drop that 1.9 trillion dollars in the
economy and they're going to slosh that
money around
so many different places they're going
to stuff it in every nook and cranny
they possibly can
and what's going to happen is that asset
prices are going to go
to the moon that's what's going to
happen
literally they are going to pump asset
prices so high
that you're literally going to be
scratching your head saying what
happened and we're going to look back
to this friday and we'll say oh my god
they passed a 1.9 trillion
stimulus package on top of that they're
now talking about another three trillion
dollars
these people have lost their minds they
think that you can create trillions and
trillions of dollars
and that you can just dump that into an
economy and there is no
adversarial or negative impact to not
only
the currency itself but also to the
bottom 45
of americans that hold no investable
assets we are about to watch
the government make the top 55 of
americans
rich like i'm talking about rich rich
i'm talking about so rich that you
literally see it in the music videos
like you're going to be making it rain
at the strip club rich
that's what they're about to do and the
bottom 45 percent of americans are about
to have their wealth absolutely
stolen from them and so not only should
people be up in arms and protesting
in terms of how absolutely absurd it is
that they're gonna do this but
second is that if you're watching this
you can say thank you because now you
know what's gonna happen so get out of
cash
invest invest invest and protect
yourself
that's all i gotta say that was not
financial advice none of that was
financial advice and i know some of
y'all watching this while you're taking
a poop
guys i got left behind i got but now you
know to invest so you won't get left
behind i got
cut out of the system i kind of liked
having that a little
intimate conversation with the people
while they're just sitting here
chilling if you were pooping let me know
well actually moist
i want to know moist have you ever
watched lunch money while you're
watching i don't want to know that
all right i don't want to know either
okay so
next game stop after a while several
weeks
the retailer's chief financial officer
resigned
the company announced tuesday that jim
bell the cfo will resign on
march 26th it started looking for a new
cfo with the capabilities and
qualifications to help accelerate
gamestop's transformation
it said hinting at the company's efforts
to shift shift its focus from physical
to online retail what was wrong with the
last cfo it seems like he was doing a
great job
i just imagine the cfo waking up one day
and being like
nah i can't deal with this no more these
reddit people they're nuts
the hedge funds they're nuts like i
don't want to be in the middle of this
war
i was gonna go take my fat bonus and
salary that i've made over the last year
or whatever
and i'm gonna go see you later dunkin
donuts
is now coming out with avocado toast
to its menu in all u.s locations it's
2.99 features a creamy
mouth-watering avocado spread consisting
of avocado sea salt black pepper and
hint of lemon juice
i have a feeling like it ain't right
it ain't right so right right
i ain't talking about this topic wait
why
america runs on duncan and nobody wants
joe avocado toast
you just want them to kill you the fast
food chain i want taco bell taco bell
we kill we try to kill you all right
next ask lunch money time hashtag ask
ellum in the comments
ready jalen wait
run your tongue across your teeth and uh
be like damn that's smooth
like no because actually i don't i still
don't have a tooth here
um so jalen
i have no tooth i have no teeth to run
my tongue
you have a bunch of teeth yeah they
don't count
jalen ware asks what is the superior ice
cream flavor you go
because i have a hot take and the people
are not gonna like it no you go
no go i don't like ice cream that's true
she doesn't like ice cream
which is blasphemous who doesn't like
ice cream someone who used to love ice
cream
and then they try to make their own and
threw up for three days in a row and
then she stopped liking ice cream
that's true i mean traumatic grow up
ah no i can't no it's it's
like it's in my genetics now
whatever comes back to me comes back and
reflects and sticks to you
you don't even know the saying you
probably got bullied in the middle
school cafeteria i did not i had many
friends
um i know that's false mint chocolate
chip
yeah god or actually that's not true
that's probably my third favorite
i have to go with cookie dough first and
then i probably have to go
with uh you love a mint chocolate no
it's my third favorite it's definitely
my third favorite
uh cookie or was it no eminem mcflurry
is probably number two
i don't even know what to make of today
okay
moist moist counter day nine of
commenting
is it day nine how do we know moist can
count
because we have a counter here every day
all right uh no voice says day nine one
day's just gonna be like day 14 and
wrong with day 14.
moyes says shaggy from scooby doo
actually isn't the worst physical
description of me
i'm just a bit less slinky though when i
tie my shoes i do the bunny ear method
when is the key word bunny ear it's all
about the loop and swoop
no i don't first of all
listen let me have a conversation with
you people
no if you do not be cut out if you tie
your
shoes loop and swoop that's the right
adult way
who just bunny ears what are you three
years old no exactly people who never
grew up
that's what i do moist moist we may be
uh what do they call it uh
soul mates we may be soul mates male
soul mates is that a weird thing that
might be a weird thing but
you know what i'm saying we got a
connection here okay bunny ear man all
right go ahead
keep going i'm just a little less lanky
when is the keyword
though because unless i'm gonna be
running or walking a lot i tend to leave
my shoes untied because it is more
uncomfortable and looks cool he does the
exact
same thing
we may be boys yesterday actually
yesterday
we went downstairs in the lobby and this
man
stopped anthony and said excuse me sir
your shoes are
untied and anthony said yay that's cause
uh
no no i i had looked at him and i said
i know that's what i hit him with i know
just leave them they look cool look
moist things they look cool i think they
look moist
actually it's because i'm lazy and i
just didn't want to tie my shoes that's
what he said
no he said he's more comfortable don't
be putting words in my boy moy's mouth
what's the next question you got from
once moist mouth did you get it
lord have mercy on us all right here's
my next question are you ready
this is a good this is trash this is a
good one no this is a good one do you
want to know the next question for
moisture are you going to keep bothering
me
golly she's like jesus
christ all right what is your next
question
moist
how many seconds do you dunk an oreo
in milk before you eat it
and if you get this wrong you're a
psychopath
how many seconds is the perfect dunk
before you eat it didn't you just give
it away but
no that wasn't the right one i'm just
saying it was uh you know it's kind of
like the mirror it says like objects may
appear closer than they appear
like you know uh simulation may occur
faster than
realities together no listen listen this
is why it's important listen
because if you a fat kid at heart you
know the answer to this question let me
know moist
see you guys tomorrow hopefully my wife
will still love me then
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends